à tous moi je vais pas vous abreuver de
slide je vais vous raconter mon mon
parcours
parce que pour les 40 ans
université de savoir où chercher de
l'expérience mais on va chercher des
anciens moi j'ai été un petit peu en
avance parce que ça fait sept ans que
j'ai 40 ans et comment se construit à 47
ans ou est-ce qu'on en est ce qu'on peut
en faire
est-ce qu'on a encore une vie après 47
ans et vous parler de la vie d'un vrai
savoyard un vrai savoyard qui est
peut-être parmi vous tout en sachant que
vous n'êtes peut-être pas savoyard vous
même vous êtes petit vous vous êtes
peut-être déjà arriver simplement ici en
savoie et je vous dirai par chance parce
que derrière à partir d'ici va se passer
quelque chose va se passer quelque chose
c'est que l'université de savoie alors
je sais qu'il ya des packs parcours
assez éclectique où des formations assez
éclectique dans la salle la réalité et
c'est mon titre c'est que la formation
elle commence aujourd'hui pour vous elle
continue pour moi et elle continuera
demain pourquoi je vous dis cela quand
on arrive dans l'université
alors bon coup de marketing maintenant
éviter polytech des formations écoles
etc
celui qui s'y retrouvent maintenant ou
après il mérite déjà peut-être une palme
parce que le parcours du combattant
étudiants dans ces logos dans ces
acronymes est quelque chose d'horrible à
vivre pour soi même pour ses parents son
entourage et pour son employeur
on vous dit aujourd'hui que demain on ne
connaît pas l'emploi vous aurez demain
donc qu'est ce que vous faites ici on
sait pas ce qu'on va vous enseignez
puisque demain vous ne savez pas ce que
vous ferez donc la réalité l'est
suffisamment simples ce constat là il
n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
il aide il y a quelques années déjà et
je les ai vécus je suis arrivé à
l'université en design l'université
c'est pas terrible
qu'est ce que tu vas faire avec ton
diplôme universitaire quel métier tu
veux faire
moi je sais pas tout ça moi je suis pas
dans une école où il ya des réseaux
j'arrive dans une université ou
l'université de savoie se résumait au
campus de jacob un petit peu marre cause
et le pôle qui est en création à
l'époque ici et sigec qui était le pôle
scientifique très bien hyper éloignez
pas de connexion globalement
l'université de savoie pas d'avenir
première chose je suis étudiant qu'est
ce que je deviens acteur de mon destin
j'apprends j'apprends pourquoi personne
celle trop vous le dire vous vous êtes
vous vous interrogez donc autant se
poser les bonnes questions quelle
cohérence sur ma formation première
cohérence aux premières constatations en
université de savoie pas de réseau
pourquoi je sors en licence je suis
sorti en licence avec une licence de
l'université de savoie
mais on est dix ans crée la première
association qui crée du réseau pour les
étudiants d'avès à l'époque
alors ça vous parle peut-être pas mais
mine de rien à l'époque faire des
annales pour les examens ça n'existait
pas demander des stages aux entreprises
ça n'était pas obligatoire avoir une
base de données pour les entreprises qui
accueillent des stagiaires
ça n'existait pas avoir de
l'informatique ça n'existe pas pourquoi
je vous dis ça je me suis dit si ça
n'existe pas autant de créer dont
création de l'association avec bien sûr
des amis des potes etc pour valoriser
notre diplôme parce que la première
chose qu'on doit apprendre quand on est
étudiant
sait on valorise sa carrière c'était
très bien dit tout à l'heure j'écoutais
mademoiselle sur le sur le parcours je
suis arrivée d orléans en cours mais la
réalité c'est ça on se construit soi
même
maintenant et pour plus tard donc avec
des copains on dit ban ou ya pas de
réseau on se le fait la vie continue on
sort je sors de licence il existait je
vous rassure il existait quand même une
maîtrise à l'époque je pas si ça parle
vous êtes trop jeune mais il n'y avait
pas de masters parce que maintenant de
maîtrise on est passé un master début de
l'ambition quand même qu'on s'est mis
donc en fait on vous a rajouté dans la
traduction de maîtrise à master nous a
juste rajouté une année d'études
enfin moi c'est ce que j'ai compris 1 2
bac + 4 ou bac à bac + 5
on a supprimé le blake +4 vous étiez
avant bac + 3 ou 4 ou 5 maintenant c'est
soit vous êtes en licence ou ya un terme
batchelor je crois si on est encore bon
en anglais pour passer avec un master
qui vous donne un bac +5 en bref tout ça
moi ça m'intéresse pas tant que ça la
réalité c'est que j'avais envie de
travailler et donc je suis parti
travailler pour voir ce que valait mon
diplôme savoyards et c'est là qu'avec
mon petit bâton de pèlerin j'ai fait de
mon parcours dans différentes
entreprises parce que quand convient de
l'université quand on n'a pas eu fait
les stages quand on vous a pas préparé à
faire des entretiens
bush et ben la vie est un peu plus dur
qu'ailleurs peut-être alors peut-être
dans des écoles de commerce on y arrive
un petit peu mieux ou au moins on vous y
prépare un petit peu mieux mais ce qui
est certain c'est que moi j'avais cette
soif de revanche de me dire ok on n'a
pas trop aidé donc tu vas te défendre
tout seul et tu vas te faire ton cv donc
j'ai fait ce qui me plaisait j'ai tapé
aux portes des activités qui me plaisait
comment commencer un petit peu dans
l'économie sociale surtout vers
responsable du développement d'une
mutuelle en région parisienne eh ben ça
m'a plu j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
voilà j'ai fait mon parcours alors un
peu de promotion interne tatati et
tatata c'est plutôt sympa on apprend un
peu de management on découvre le
marketing ça m'a permis de découvrir
l'informatique la vie comme terrain de
formation c'est qu'une fois qu'on a
trouvé la première entreprise qui
commencent à vous dire tiens ce gala il
a quand même peut-être un peu de
potentiel
vous pouvez aussi aller me dire à
l'entreprise si moi j'ai du potentiel là
falloir nourrir nourrir de tout ce que
j'ai pas eue
qu'est ce que j'ai pu je vous disais
j'ai pas eu d'informatique et ses pas et
c'est pas un mensonge on avait pas de
salle informatique
oui avec windows oui on était encore
presque à la génération des sorties
d'été au 7 août et aux neuf là vous
pourrez demander à vos parents je pense
qu'elle rappellera quelques souvenirs on
programmait plus qu'on savait utiliser
un traitement de texte et ben
l'entreprise pour le court devient votre
premier allié c'est l'entreprise qui va
vous formez donc du coup j'ai pris tout
ce qu'il y avait à prendre dans
l'entreprise et je me suis collé
derrière du traitement de texte le
tableur de la base de données etc
pour comprendre ce qu'on vous disait
quelques parents mailing etc pour
pouvoir le faire et c'est comme ça que
j'ai progressé
donc mon parcours professionnel à
continuer comme ça et puis naturellement
parcours de vie oblige parcours de jeune
papa arrivent après c'est un choix aussi
personnel il n'y a pas d'obligation n'y
a pas d'âge pour le faire et il se
trouve le fait de l'histoire personnelle
coup double
à 27 ans deux filles jumelles alors
sympa non pas pour un papa qui veulent
un garçon
résultat une cour à une grossesse
compliquée pas que pour moi
pour la maman tellement compliqué qu'on
se retrouve du coup coincé à l'hôpital
prince à l'hôpital quand vous pouvez pas
travailler parce que eh ben les petites
étaient là et voilà les deux merveilles
du monde
si la maman est hospitalisé parce que
c'est compliqué qu'est ce qu'on fait et
bah du coup on s'arrête un moment on
s'arrête un moment et la formation
le terrain de la vie on s'occupe de ses
enfants
mais bon c'est à dire ça que pour les
femmes on a quand même un petit peu de
temps à ça dort au milieu etc
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pendant ce
temps difficiles où mon épouse doit se
remettre sur pied de cet accouchement
difficile épreuve de la vie eh ben j'ai
enseigné
j'ai enseigné pendant un an et je peux
m'en d'orgueil ir aujourd'hui d'avoir 20
bacheliers qui ont ma signature de prof
principal en économie et gestion
ça vous blesse ça comme ça
un gars qui partait comme ça qu'ils
s'arrêtent en milieu pour une raison qui
était très très simple en réalité c'est
que parmi toutes les vicissitudes de
l'enseignement universitaire où on vous
change la règle à chaque année il en est
une qu'il fallait retenir c'est que le
rectorat qui va à la vitesse du vent
quand même avait matérialisé le fait
qu'un mec puisse 3 suffisait pour
renseigner sur ce précepte là j'ai
présenté une candidature je me suis
retrouvé prof donc pendant un an je me
suis retrouvée de l'autre côté de la
barrière
et là encore la vie comme terrain de
formation et ben oui c'est vrai que la
vie de prof c'est pas facile tellement
pas facile que j'ai donné du meilleur
que je pouvais pour que la promotion
mais que j'avais en charge sur un tel
professeur principal et bien de bons
résultats transmettre un petit peu
l'idée que j'avais de la vie mais
tellement difficile quand même que j'ai
pas voulu continuer parce que
franchement c'est difficile d'être
enseignant faut le reconnaître et je
pense que c'est une vraie vocation
alors je pense avoir une peut-être une
fibre pédagogique mais pas suffisante
pour passer quand même
toute ma carrière derrière derrière un
bureau comme ça a donné des
renseignements pour des métiers que je
ne connais pas moi même donc j'avais
aussi une cohérence avec avec mon propos
du jour pas trouvé forcément la
pertinence dans mon rôle tel comme
l'imposait peut-être plus sur
d'accompagnement du coaching un jour
peut-être ça viendra chacun ses
objectifs mais en tout cas
l'enseignement en tout cas basiques tels
qu'on peut le connaître enfin peut-être
tel que je le connais c'est l époque pas
forcément vocation pour moi donc
résultats et la bbc se remet sur le
marché du travail il reprend son bâton
de pèlerin et là il retrouve sa voix
chargée de ses deux enfants sa femme
rétabli il revient en savoie et et
continuer à construire son parcours son
parcours en disant tiens si je faisais
un peu du concret quand on est de
l'université alors là il ya des
techniciens je prends ma salle sa
tranche du technicien c'est pas
péjoratif des ingénieurs en futur
ingénieur en bâtiment sciences physiques
ou autre moi j'étais rien de tout ça
parce que quand on vous colle
l'étiquette administration économique et
sociale ça vous fait d'un côté vous êtes
fonctionnaire de l'autre côté vous serez
gratte papier donc dans le privé donc
des deux côtés c'est pas forcément le
très très vendeur donc je me suis donné
l'idée de me faire un petit parcours
très concret dans le bâtiment est là
comment on fait quand vous sortez
d'université pour aller dans le bâtiment
dans votre avis et bah pareil on prend
son comprends c'est sa canne de pèlerin
et on va taper à la première entreprise
qui croient en vous avant de croire à
votre diplôme et là un premier
industriel qui me prend industrielle du
chauffage dont j'ai appris la thermique
deuxième industrielle la régulation
thermique l'étagé du dessus du chauffage
parce que j'ai changé je faisais des
cycles de deux ans je prenais la
formation bonjour monsieur regardez
regardez la pêche que j'ai etc
ça va marcher derrière jean briller sur
toutes les formations de la boutique et
hop on trouver autre chose et je me suis
construit mon parcours comme ça
résultat des courses en 2005 je rentre
la plus belle industrie française et qui
reste la manufacture de versailles c'est
saint gobain en fait oui le grand groupe
saint gobain nationaliser quand 86 alors
là ça remonte pour certains jean louis
beffa et bien j'ai eu la chance moi de
rentrer dans ce groupe
le groupe industriel par excellence qui
dirige tout dans le monde
enfin au moins en france un cas par cas
la paire point.p isover placoplâtre
aujourd'hui bref le monde du bâtiment
la reconnaissance absolue je rentre chez
saint gobain et l'a tellement bien avec
mon bon parcours de solitaire
d'indépendants aidé envie de
envie d'avancer tout simplement je vais
pas dire je me sent à l'étroit ce serait
vraiment prétentieux mais par contre à
travers leur formation et là encore je
remercie le grandiloquent saint gobain
de l'avoir largement formée je vois
émerger le marché de la de l'isolation
thermique qui explose vous êtes de la
génération qui va faire la révolution
écologique
donc il va faire la rénovation et la
révolution énergétique des bâtiments est
là quand on passe de pas d'isolation a
beaucoup d'isolation avec de
l'étanchéité à l'air avec des
interrogations suivre les formaldéhydes
qui circulent c'est à dire la qualité de
l'air naturellement
et là pour le coup les métiers qui
n'existent pas apparaissent des
diagnostiqueurs sur le bâtiment sur la
qualité de l'air etc tous ces métiers
d'art arrive et derrière une industrie
s'organise donc qui dit industrie dit
production qui dit production il ya un
moment recherche de clients et à point
nommé j'ai donc décidé suivant un marché
en expansion de me lancer de prendre une
entreprise qui allait distribuer le
marché qui est l'être le marché de
demain le marché de la performance
énergétique le marché d'isolation donc
j'ai créé cette entreprise et la
réussite à travers de l'accompagnement
en formation avec les chambres
consulaires
donc on retrouve toujours encore une
fois de la formation mais de la
formation cette fois ci pour ce pur soit
parce que l'objectif que j'avais tout
simplement c'était de réussir ou pas
pour moi c'est pas une c'est pas une
quête du graal personnel mais en
attendant mon choix personnel d'être
créateur d'entreprise ou plutôt de créer
ou développer un marché et fallait être
accompagnés parce que je pense qu'aucune
mission
aucune personne ne peut se dire j'ai le
savoir et je vais me débrouiller tout
seul la réalité c'est que même temps
devenant en continuant mon chemin d'être
indépendant mon chemin d'être créateur
d'entreprise ou chef d'entreprise est
bon le fait jamais tout seul il faut
être accompagné et se former au
quotidien parce que oui j'avais senti le
marché mais oui il marchait allait
encore changer
suivent la réglementation thermique la
réglementation thermique moi j'ai connu
la réglementation thermique 2012
aujourd'hui on en est à 2020 a toujours
un petit temps d'avancé
on parle de maison passive du bbc de
bibelots etc tous ces termes là il ya
moins de dix ans n'étaient même pas au
catalogue
larousse aujourd'hui ça n'est donc vous
avez une obligation non seulement à vous
adapter
mais à toujours regarder ce qui se
passera devant pour continuer à être
performants de cette idée d'indépendance
c'est bien c'est bien quand on a trouvé
vraiment son chemin et c'est quand on
est épanouie et il se trouve que je suis
quelqu'un un petit peu d'insatiable vous
allez me dire très bavard ou trop rapide
je ne sais pas la réalité c'est qu'il
manquait quelque chose
une corde à mon arc parce qu'on peut
avoir un tempérament de développeur
mais c'est surtout de l'envié de
développer aussi pour les autres et
c'est le deuxième moment de ma vie où le
terrain politique
mas n'ont pas tendu les bras parce que
en fait personne ne vous attend vous
avez pris la petite porte qui s'ouvre et
du coup vous êtes rentré dedans et je
suis rentré dedans comme tout mon
parcours
donc je suis rentré par la porte en
apprenant en écoutant en regardant et je
suis rentré conseil municipal je suis
devenu adjoint je me suis intéressé et
la politique du terrain celle qui parle
de vraie celle qui peut défendre une
commune comme qui peut défendre la
savoie comme qui peut défendre des
étudiants tels que vous êtes
il me semblait l'avoir chevillée au
corps pour être élu conseiller
départemental en 2015 et maire de la
commune dans laquelle je réside
aujourd'hui dans notre belle savoie
alors pourquoi je vous dis ça il n'y a
pas d'obligation bien sûr à faire de la
politique mais ce sera mon message de
conclusion on n'est jamais assez fort
mais on s'implique jamais assez est donc
derrière tout ça on doit être animé
d'une curiosité qu'il faudra savoir
partagé si vous la partagez un vous
aurez le retour de l'autre vous aurez le
débrief immédiatement de vos idées donc
ça il faut accepter d'aller au carton
sur des idées de la confrontation ça la
politique là dessus c'est impitoyable
mais tout autant dans l'entreprise
quand vous avez une idée elle est là
confrontés c'est le partage des idées
qui vous fait avancer
donc soyez curieux impliquez vous dans
cette curiosité
partagez là avec d'autres et vous verrez
que les autres vous le rendront est
naturellement l'expérience du monde qui
bouge sera la vôtre parce que vous
l'aurez toucher du bois vous y aurez
simplement participer alors il ya
beaucoup de bois terme autour de ça
co construit on est proactif et c'est
oublier le registre de tout ça regardez
juste que vous avez vous là dedans
le moteur que vous avez il marche dans
un monde qui bouge donc rester dans ce
mouvement là de curiosité de formation
maintenant et pour tout le temps moi je
suis à peine à la moitié de quelque
chose je me dis que c'est après que ce
sera intéressant
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
aujourd'hui merci de votre attention
j'espère que vous comprendrez tout ça
[Applaudissements]